ja
ja wo fange ich an
einerseits hat es mich maßlos geärgert
was jetzt herausgekommen ist
andererseits freue ich mich dass diese
wandlitz blase von öffentlich
rechtlichen rundfunk radio berlin dran
wird vielleicht kommen andere noch nach
endlich geplatzt ist endlich geplatzt
ist wir haben das teuerste öffentlich
rechtliche rundfunk und fernseh wesen
auf der welt mit 8,4 milliarden jährlich
zwangs finanziert war 100 millionen
werbeeinnahmen kommen noch mit dazu ja
und werde ich sage wandlitz blasenwand
lich syndrom jenigen die ddr ein
bisschen kennen müssen was das bedeutet
bonds im viertel wandlitz da durfte man
nicht reinschauen die haben mit west
gütern da und wird westfernsehen
natürlich alles gehabt in saus und braus
und haben auch wohl los gefahren
vielleicht auch mit massagesitzen ich
weiß es nicht es ist gut dass das
endlich geplatzt ist weil hier der fall
ist so genannte mediale elite
völlig abgehoben hat völlig abgehoben
hat mit gehältern und boni wie weit das
übersteigen was ein bundespräsident und
der bundeskanzler bekommt mit direktoren
mit jahresgehältern von 180.000 240.000
euro weit über dem was ein minister weil
in den minister zum beispiel in einem
bundesland mit großer verantwortung hat
da stimmt was nicht da stimmt was nicht
und dass da endlich erleuchtet wurde und
ich hoffe dass die staatsanwaltschaften
das noch tun und ich wünsche mir vor
allem auch dass die kontrollgremien
die es dort gibt es gibt verwaltungsräte
es gibt fernsehräte dass sie endlich mal
im job nachkommen aber sie sind da
verzeihen sie sind nach einem
proporzsystem die ngo muss bedient
werden die partei muss bedient werden
die kirche muss bedient werden sind sie
zusammen gebastelt worden
ich bin hier ausnahmen auch sie können
auch einen ganz besonders dem
bayerischen rundfunk ja der sich auch
sehr kritisch geäußert denn wenn sie
sich jetzt hier sind unsere austauschen
bildet die ausnahme die ausnahme die sie
sagen vermag worten markwort hat sich
keine freunde gemacht im rundfunk
ich frage mich wo war der rundfunkrat
war wo war die fortschrittliche
rundfunkrat ist die ja nun mittlerweile
auch twitter ist es noch einmal zusammen
für die zuschauer dies vielleicht
mitbekommen haben den fall schlesinger
das muss man ja wir haben zusammen die
frau schlesinger hat boni leuchten nicht
mitgerechnet ein jahreseinkommen von
303.000 euro gehabt das halte ich für
schon ein bisschen obst schöne jetzt in
dem vergleich mit bundespräsident und
und bundes wenn sie hat ein gamescom
invite km/h mittel dazu war eine luxus
güte mit dazu autos mit massagesitzen es
kamen offensichtlich an den üblichen
ausschreibungsverfahren mit hinzu
millionenbeträge für die neue
ausstattung eines büros private feste
auch die den upgrade fahrerin ja während
übrigens der kleine redakteur oder der
freie feste freie mitarbeiter relativ
dürftig aber trafen letzte frau
schlesinger wurde ja auch abberufen kann
man das vielleicht auch als wendepunkt
sehen ist weil das erhoffen das ist ein
wendepunkt jemand ab wo sie hoffe dass
in der zdf-reihe leuchtet wird die gdf
hat die größe und ich glaube man muss
auch sagen dass nicht in allen
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunkanstalten
der länder also solche bedingungen sind
die bedingungen ja
rein geleuchtet habe ich möchte
eingeleuchtet haben am ende ergab weiß
inventur und da sieht es bei hanna
minisender
warum müssen wir radio bremen haben und
sagen wir müssen wir saarländischen
rundfunk haben warum kann man die nicht
zusammen packen aber das weiß ich nicht
was ich mir gerade vor stelle ich meine
die falsche lösung ist schon ein
herausragender fall aber ich glaube
nicht dass sie ein einzelfall ist und
ich stelle meinen fast bildlich vor den
verschiedenen sendern die intendanten
die direktoren und sonst welche
führungscrew der verzweifelt sagen oh
gott den stuhl bestellt den stuhl sofort
wird er ab diesen tollen stuhl ist ein
beruf stuhl da werden ja schon
renovierungen von büros werden schon
wieder zurückgenommen und was sind mal
den berühmten massagestuhl in dem
dienstwagen betrifft
gehört ja zu fast zur pflichtausstattung
von
aber vor dass diese diese diese umgang
mit öffentlichen geldern ist es sind ja
öffentliche gelder die wir bezahlen dass
ich glaube dass davor schließlich einsam
und variiert die zahl die 18 euro der
muss er nass das absitzen er auch diese
fälle haben wir nein ich möchte dass der
weg beschritten wird wie es teilweise
die franzosen eingeschlagen haben sie
waren die rundfunk gebühren abschaffen
ich möchte sie abschaffen immer ich mit
einem eher gezänks angaben
konkurrenzkampf zwischen den privaten
haben und den öffentlich-rechtlichen
haben oder sage ich noch etwas wir haben
aber einen doppelten
verfassungsrechtlichen schutz also die
rechtlichen grundlagen sind völlig
andere und ich finde es auch gut dass
wir eine medienlandschaft haben die
öffentlich-rechtliche und private sender
hat hier wie in deutschland die sich
auch ein bisschen ergänzen die ein
bisschen anderes profil haben wo ich ein
recht gebe da also ich finde auch 300
3000 euro für eine intendantin einer
landesrundfunkanstalt das muss nicht
sein aber auch dort ist es so dass die
so geschützt sind durch
verfassungsgerichtliche urteile dass
mit dem urteil auf wir haben so
staatsvertrag die haben wir auch dort
heißt es dass alle einer gebühr erhöhung
zustimmen müssen dann stimmt das land
sachsen-anhalt dagegen bzw macht das
nicht mit und dann haben wir diesen
ersten senat angeführt von einem
gewissen herrn professor hart ja ehemals
stellvertretender cdu csu
fraktionsvorsitzender und merkel
juristischer merkel berater und so
weiter und dann wird das einfach
durchgehen könnte sich in der ein weil
er mal eben merkel berater war ich
glaube die unabhängigkeit des
verfassungsgerichts sollten wir jetzt
hier nicht ein verfassungsgericht hat
selbst ihr renommee erspielt haben
nämlich das klima urteil
nehme ich die kolonisten windows allem
ihr
urteil inhalt die gewaltenteilung
funktionieren kommen auch mal das
verfassungsgericht das versprechen aber
jetzt reden wir einmal über den inhalt
und zwei feurige mit ihnen würde ich
schon seine sitzt hier auch eine
insiderin am tisch leer wie lange die
bambi-verleihung gemeinsam mit dem
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
ausgerichtet ungefähr 20 jahre 20 jahre
da werden sie auch viele kennen gelernt
habe wie empfinden sie denn den
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk ganz
persönlichen auch das programm dort
das ist eine schwierige frage ich schaue
sehr viel fernsehen
ich liebe die dritten programme
ich liebe auch arte
und ich gucke mir da also viele
sendungen an die mitte ist persönlich
gefallen
aber das aber sag mal ob das öffentlich
rechtliche fernsehen seinem seinem
kulturellen auftrag nachkommt das möchte
ich dann schon doch in vielen fällen
bezweifeln ja in welchen fällen zum
beispiel wann immer es um serien geht um
filme usw also ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass der öffentlich-rechtliche auftrag
sehr viel mehr
kultur sehr viel mehr politik und sehr
viel mehr
wissenssendungen bedeuten sollte und war
nicht mehr zum beispiel nein das kann
ich jetzt nicht ich kann dich sagen
diese eine sendung ist jetzt schlecht
oder brauchen wir gern
wenn der sprachlichen durch die
öffentlich-rechtliche und darum ging es
uns sagen ich habe doch war dies eine
wunderbare sendung es wurde uns
vorgeworfen dass wir damit reklame für
den burda-verlag machen aber
letztendlich war bambi eine eine
preisverleihung für menschen mit
herausragenden
fähigkeiten talenten oder
missionen aber durchaus geschafft über
den menschen gesagt haben das wäre für
sie lieber beim privatfernsehen weil sie
finde der öffentlich rechtliche auftrag
ist es nicht nein also dass das fand ich
dann schon das fand ich schon okay weil
das wir haben ja auch
das von einer reinen
unterhaltungssendung haben wir das so
einem ganz anderen sendung
gestaltet ja also es war sehr viel mehr
inhalt und sehr viel mehr
ernsthaftigkeit dass das finde ich schon
in ordnung aber ich
glaube einfach dass das die
das ist eine gewisse großmannssucht eine
verschobene eine freude an der
verschwendung und kein und kein
verhältnis so zu öffentlichen geldern in
vielen sendern gibt ja also das wird
einfach ausgegeben und es wird immer
mehr verlangt ja es sollen die gebühren
sollen erhöht werden und im übrigen
übernehmen natürlich auch die
öffentlich-rechtlichen sendern auch sehr
viele bereiche die eigentlich nur die
privaten haben sollten ja so einhellig
entscheiden sie dennoch öffentlich
rechtliches herr ja zwangsläufig weil
wir unter wasser das an effekten sie ist
gern mit schwiegereltern das gucken muss
weil wohnung oder einem haus katastrophe
aber mir geht's laufen was werden sie
denn gezwungen tagesschau tage schauen
heute
und das ganze warum also mir geht es
nicht nur um das geld ja ich will wäre
tatsächlich bereit als normaler bürger
auch das geld zu bezahlen aber ich habe
kein hundertprozentiges vertrauen mehr
zum öffentlichen rechtlichen rundfunk
ich sage ihnen auch warum weil ich das
einmal als sich aus eines ehemaligen
polizeibeamten der ich mal war sehe dass
viele dinge einfach ich behaupte mal
bewusst verschwiegen werden zwei
landwirtschaft ein absolut dramatisches
thema es geht immer nur in eine richtung
ist mit immer nur drauf grauen von 99
sendungen sind wirklich oder von 100
sendungen 99 wirklich gegen
landwirtschaft bewusst und nicht fakten
orientiert als beste beispiel waffen es
wäre unrealistisch nennen ja ich bin ein
linkslastig ich würde dich fühlst
du hast nicht also da ist
es ist frühling ist es ja ein bewusstes
timing und zwar das beste beispiel war
der gutachten der türkischen
demokratie eigentlich haben muss man
sagen ist der öffentlich-rechtliche
rundfunk auch die quellenkritik
wesentlich besser geworden dem gesagt
wird aber umschlagen können wenn ich
nach aber rechtliche rundfunk hatte
bislang ein man muss schon sagen wenn
man sieht interviews mit selensky wenn
man sieht ich möchte jetzt nicht mein
eigenes haus loben und meinen kollegen
paul ronzheimer aber alle exklusiven
informationen kamen fast ausnahmslos von
bauern selber und der bild oder wenn man
sagt der öffentlich rechtliche auftrag
also ich wollte nur sagen das ist wenn
kritik weil sie gesagt habe der
öffentlich rechtlichen fonds unkritisch
ja ich lebe doch dass man mit auch gut
informiert ist die
regierungsfreundliche kritisch würde ich
habe ihm gesagt also
qualität von 80 prozent der journalisten
im öffentlich rechtlichen bereich an die
untersuchungen von professor kettwiger
die umfrage und der volontären die in
der ard ja da machen rot grün 80 prozent
und das merkt man auch bisher in
unterhaltungssendungen es gibt doch fast
einen
tatort mehr der nicht auf wo knecht
getrimmt ist